I love you you're so sweet this is
horrible to do to a person who loves
animals I do not need more animals oh my
god but there to tell adorable if you
all get these puppies and you separate
these sisters I will haunt you when I'm
dead
[Music]
hey what's up yo I'm Kelly Clarkson and
I am hanging out with puppies so I'll
answering y'all's questions so it's
basically the best afternoon ever okay
here we go let's start you want it you
want this one if something went down and
you had one phone call to get someone to
help you out who do you call Blake
Shelton's Adam Levine or Alicia Keys oh
it depends on the scenario I mean I
think I'd call Blake we've I know him a
little better than the others but I
don't know I feel like Adam could charm
my way out of a situation and Alicia
Keys has this weird gravitational pull
to like humans so she could help me out
too I don't know people fall for this
southern charm I'd probably call Blake
call him have you heard from any of the
people who influenced meaning of life
Toni Braxton Bonnie Raitt Michelle Obama
right sorry it's so weird that you say
this because I did get a handwritten
letter from Michelle Obama about go high
which I obviously wrote inspired by the
message you know she gave it to
Democratic convention that's why I said
it to her um they like to tickle your
toes okay let's um he likes my rainbow
nails um you've got a subsequent legend
it's an emergency and you need a
babysitter's Simon Cowell koalas do love
Justin Guarini
I like a person that can discipline so
I'm probably gonna pick a diamond and
here's a kid oh now so he knows how to
lay down the law
watch him actually be a softie with kids
though hey you want to play what did you
do to Julie's name a Disney character
you'd love to sing a duet with that's
hard
I actually really dig Pocahontas the
voice of Pocahontas I think her voice is
amazing
she was just we had you know I feel like
a lot of the princesses are like damsels
and she was like I got this John Smith
follow me like I loved her my daughter
loves Pocahontas to tickle you like
pantyhose my man
what is one
you learned from the artists on your
team on the voice um I get I think you
attacked no no I guess I'd say I don't
really get nervous so it's been kind of
a thing to help people with nervous
energy I don't actually know that I'm
helpful cuz I'm like just get over it
you might suck you might regret hate
your fun you know but probably just how
to really be a coach and you know
instead of me just doing I have to kind
of help like mold and teach they're
everywhere out of it I mean does he love
me or what like he has not left me I
love you let me answer another one
wouldn't you want to help me what's the
first thing you do when you find
yourself home alone
oh I cry of happiness um you I I don't
know I guess I grab a glass of wine
y'all that's not that's few and far
between we have four kids so and oh oh
my gosh okay so in 2012 you said you had
a killer song that you wanted paint Gaga
and Jesse J to sing with you what
happened to that well no one answered
no one answered my call I didn't
actually call him I just sent it on
Twitter cuz I'm gonna be awkward if they
didn't wanna do it
so um but I did it was the song that was
actually ended up on my album piece by
piece and it was called dance with me
come on and dance with me it's like this
like Bowie kind of Abba vibe and I loved
it and like literally you're so
beautiful and you will not leave me and
I love him what song would you really
like to cover as a fan request on your
next tour anything from the Harry Styles
album I love it or evolve imagine
dragons that's good I love I love both
those albums right now they're pretty
rad or kardi because I just think it'd
be fun to watch me sing like red bottoms
shoot those budgets would be bad red
bottom heels no way that's that wrong
feet already I'm not it's not a fit I've
grown up listening to so many of your
songs which one is your favorite to
perform whoo
my favorite old-school song like from
the beginning is miss independent still
live it's so much better than on record
my favorite new song ever to perform
like above all it's a whole lot of woman
off this new album meaning of life it is
it gives me life on so many levels
oh my god on my I can this is the worst
situation for me I'm gonna buy all these
dogs or take them Paul
what is the silliest gift you have ever
received what it was at a show and a
girl threw me her Brawl and it was
supposed to be funny like we support you
get it but I was like this is not an
Aerosmith concert lose it Kelly Clarkson
concert like but it was funny
so points were being clever I would have
a beer at you I would have some wine
with you I don't really enjoy beer too
much if you can seem up with four other
badass women to form a girl band who
would you pick oh I'd probably pick who
I said earlier that I wanted to sing I'd
I pick pink and Jesse J I mean I love so
many of doubt at least Keys like this I
pick a bunch of just like soulful singer
there's a lot of women I love Demi I
love Sammy what was it like to finally
meet Steve Carell in person and how did
you feel about that it was awesome you
know I was awesome because he was
actually really cool sometimes you meet
people and that doesn't happen exactly
they know what I'm talking about
exactly that's what you want to do to
him okay one more
did you ever vote for anyone else while
you were on American Idol did you ever
vote for yourself
I never never voted on my season not
even for myself which is dumb like I
should have I really don't need a dog
like
but somebody does you need to love you
need this love and like why would you
not want this look at this this is
loyalty this is you're just like it's
storytime
Oh your eyes I'm getting sucked into the
vortex my husband will kill me y'all so
if you wanted even come on
they're so cute we got leo Thelma Louise
got copper and look at they want a home
they need a home and you can do it
puppies are so much cooler than humans
like come on alright so if you want one
of y'all gotta look up North Shore
Animal League America you gotta find
them you got it you got to make a little
friend for life and don't separate the
sisters please come on get film elites
together they could be buddies he's
taking it down I love these dogs